and the president has said nothing in
public about claims of sexual misconduct
by Republican Senate candidate Roy Moore
the former Alabama Chief Justice made a
brief statement to reporters yesterday
then stepped aside while event
organizers blocked questions about those
allegations Dean Reynolds is in
Birmingham Alabama with the latest on
this story dean good morning good
morning well except for an appearance on
Fox News earlier in the week judge Moore
has not answered reporters questions
about allegations of sexual misconduct
since those allegations emerged last
week and yesterday in Birmingham it was
more of the same a supportive
conservative crowd from around the
country gathered yesterday to praise the
judge who continued to make clear he has
no plans to quit I'll quit standing when
they lay me in that box and put me in
the ground
more's campaign initially build this
event as a press conference but it ended
in a frenzy of unanswered question he's
answered that question repeatedly let's
take the next question he's already
answered that question with reporters
asking about recurring allegations that
Moore once had inappropriate
interactions with young women Moore
walked away from those questions
protected by event organizers and
received a police escort but the
controversy accompanied him as well he
maintains the support of Alabama's
Republican Party which said Thursday he
deserves to be presumed innocent adding
that voters will make the ultimate
decision but the national GOP wants
little or nothing to do with him with
many Republican lawmakers supporting his
accusers and mulling ways to block his
path to Washington we have called for
him to withdraw from the race and that
is the right thing to do president Trump
made an appearance on Capitol Hill
Thursday but ignored questions about
more that President believes that these
allegations are very troubling and he
thinks that the people of Alabama should
make the decision on who their next
senator should be a new poll shows
Democrat Doug Jones leading more in the
Senate race by eight points now among
likely voters with less than a month to
until the special election before these
allegations emerged other polls show
this was a pretty close race here in
Alabama now the question becomes whether
Moore has enough time to make up the
ground that he's apparently lost Norah
all right Dean thank you so much and we
should note that special election is set
for December 12th